hello there today we'll look at
pondernet learning to ponder by andrea
bonino jan balaguer and charles blundell
this paper on a high level introduces a
recurrent architecture or a principle of
recurrent computation for deep networks
that essentially says the network
recurrently computes its output at each
step and at each step it can decide to
stop now because it is satisfied with
the answer that it has the idea is that
at a complex task you can compute for
many steps because it requires many
steps of thinking
and then give the output and for an easy
task the network can decide to output
right away because it already has
computed the solution
this decision can be done
on a per sample basis so for each sample
the network can decide when it's time to
give the final output and
this is this is
not necessarily a paper that just you
know makes something bigger and then
pushes state-of-the-art on some
benchmark and that's
why it piqued my interest is that it
tries to re rephrase a little bit how we
think about the connection of deep
learning and algorithms like classic
algorithms by themselves essentially
this is a dynamic if condition in this
algorithm that decides when it's when
it's time to stop
and i appreciate that you know it not
everything has to be
state of the art pushing here this is
simply
a cool method to do something that's
relatively new
of course uh things like this have been
done before and they are discussed at
length in this paper how this paper is
different from other papers that do
similar things and it does push
state-of-the-art just not on benchmarks
that you might be super duper familiar
with um but yeah it's it's a cool paper
it's a short paper the idea is pretty
simple and it appears to work and um
yeah that's exciting stuff so
we're gonna dive into this paper have a
look have a look at what's new in this
particular model how it works and yeah
as always if you have feedback leave a
comment
subscribe i'd be happy for that and
yeah thanks for being here
okay so in the abstract here they say
that in a standard neural network the
amount of computation used grows with
the size of the inputs
but not with the complexity of the
problem being learned
so
which is true right in a standard neural
network you have a forward pass
be that in a fully connected neural
network where you have you know you have
your input and then you go layer layer
layer layer layer and then you have your
output this
computation here is always the same no
matter the input even in a recurrent
neural network right you have
kind of an input
right here at the beginning you have a
layer then you have an input again and
then you have this that goes into the
same layer and then you have the next
input that goes into the same layer even
a recurrent neural network usually
usually um
just does the same forward pass this is
a little bit different if you have
something like a language model that can
emit at some point a you know a stop
token
or an end of sentence token at which
point the computation essentially stops
but it's a little bit of a different
thing than we consider right here right
here
we consider a neural network that has to
find the answer to a particular problem
and we're going to see the problems um
down but one problem that they present
is the parity problem so the parity
problem is you get a string of zeros and
ones
i think there's also negative ones in
there but i think they're bit for a
distraction
and
the answer you're looking for is um
as a whole is the parity so the amount
of ones in this string odd or even right
so this requires a
let's say
an integrated view of computation this
is essentially a classic algorithm that
you have to perform over this string and
neural networks as good as they are in
computer vision and speech recognition
they are having trouble with a simple
algorithmic tasks like this so the idea
of of this paper here is that
well
it doesn't make sense to apply a neural
network that always does the same amount
of compute right i shove this sequence
just like in here it
doesn't make sense because
you know if there is just a single
one in the string and i see that right
away i can give the answer right away
however if there's if it's a long string
and there's a bunch of ones i might need
to think about this problem for a while
and thus adapt the number of computation
steps i do in my head i might you know
first
if i look at this string i might first
connect these two you know and then ah
that's two and then i might connect
these two that's two again and then i
might connect these two that's four
there's nothing here there's nothing
here right okay four so that's kind of
like one two
three steps of computation so that's the
the rough idea whereas this if the
string was shorter and and
more regular i might need less
computation
so they say to overcome this limitation
we introduce
pondernet a new algorithm that learns to
adapt the amount of computation based on
the complexity of the problem at hand um
pondernet learned end to end the number
of computational steps to achieve an
effective compromise between training
prediction accuracy computational cost
and generalization
so we are going to see how they do this
um
yeah exactly so they then they go into
the the task their experimental tasks in
this paper are are sort of these
um constructed tasks where people know
you need this dynamic computation
they're not gonna they're not gonna
compete on like imagenet or something
like this
so the
major majority of the paper is in
um
in contra posing their model
against this act model the adaptive
computation time i believe
so there have been previous attempts
at doing dynamic computation time yet
either they
have um
so
it turns out
they're kind of finicky and um this
model here this pondernet model has a
bunch of advantages
they say they present pondernet that
builds on the previous ideas
it's fully differentiable which allows
for low variance gradient estimates
unlike reinforce so a couple of previous
attempts have been with reinforcement
learning so let's just learn
the number of steps or when to stop
using reinforcement learning
and that as you might know is very very
noisy
it has unbiased gradient estimates which
is also unlike other models in the past
and
yeah so they say
this has consequences in all three in
all aspects of the model
in pondernet the halting node predicts
the probability of halting conditional
or not having halted before
this kind of seems obvious but
apparently that no one has done this so
far
so what do we need for an architecture
for pondernet they say this down here
um
essentially that's the architecture it's
an inline formula which you know but
that's the architecture so what you need
is you need an
input okay
you need an input which is
x your input
and x is transformed into a hidden state
this is let's say the hidden state at
step one
those two
or you can also reformulate this as just
a hidden state the hidden state is going
into s the so-called step function and
that's the recurrent function right here
so into this step function you can put
anything you want you can put like a cnn
inside you can treat this as an lstm
since we're going to apply it
recursively
sorry recurrently and
anything you want can be the step
function as long as it can be applied
recurrently
so this step function is going to give
you the next hidden state right so you
can see it's a recurrent neural network
however it is also going to give you
um the output at that particular point
in time so uh
y one i guess that'll be here and it's
also going to give you this number
lambda n
now
what are these so
from here you could apply the step
function again you'd get h3 you get the
output two and you'd get lambda sorry
that's that's a one that's a two
okay so
it seems like it's a just a recurrent
neural network and if i were to put push
this to the end right i go give my hhh
and then at the end i get my yn and i
treat that as the output of the
computation then it's just a recurrent
neural network however as we said the
network can in this case decide to stop
anywhere in between for example if it
decides to stop
at this particular step then that would
be the output of the computation so
every computation step the network
computes and a potential output a
suggestion for an output and then it
also thinks about whether or not it
really wants to answer with that output
or whether it wants to continue and to
do another step essentially take another
shot at answering the question because
it doesn't yet have the correct um
answer
and that's where this lambda
thing comes in so the lambda is a
probability of
stopping essentially
so here you can see the output lambda is
a number between 0 and 1
and that is the probability of halting
this is the
output
considered that the
network halts
so whenever this is one the network will
halt
conditioned on the fact that it hasn't
previously halted yeah it seemed as i
said it seems obvious to formulate it
like this because you can you know you
can only halt if you haven't previously
halted but apparently previous models
have simply output a number that is sort
of the probability of halting in general
which
doesn't give you
a bias sorry an unbiased gradient if you
try to back propagate through it
so if you consider the lambdas to be
like this if you unroll for an entire
training run then you get um
you get the probability of halting at
any particular step this one so this is
what
um
this is what
the previous networks would have
estimated directly however this network
estimates these lambdas these ones here
so you can see how you can compute the
probability that for example the network
halts after three steps
by multiplying up the probability that
network has not halted which is this one
at step one has not halted at step two
and then the probability that network
halts at step three that it given that
it hasn't halted at the previous steps
so that is a valid probability
distribution it's a generalization of
the geometric uh distribution and
essentially it encapsulates a decision
tree right so
you're at the beginning
you can halt sorry let's go a halt or
not or continue
if you continue then again you can halt
or you can continue if again you can
halt or continue and so on
and
all of this
so if you want the probability that the
network
halts after you know
this the third step then you would
consider this node which means that
you'd multiply you that you multiply up
these paths right here and that's the
probability that it holds after three
steps
okay so
the network can output this lambda at
every step if the lambda is high
then the network halts
of course at inference this is done
probabilistically
now at training time this is done a
little bit differently so you i hope you
can see at inference time you simply go
forward and you get a lambda maybe the
lambda in the first step is
uh 0.1
and then you flip a coin a biased coin
right if
if it comes up pads you stop with the
probability of 0.1 if it comes up tails
which is a 0.9 probability you continue
then maybe at the second step it's it's
um 0.05
so
maybe maybe you stop but probably you
won't stop and then at the third step
it like comes up 0.9 the network thinks
yeah i should probably stop here and you
sample from that and yes you you might
indeed in nine out of ten cases you
actually stop there so that's inference
um how about training
how about we train this thing um during
training what we do is
again we input x
our input into an encoder for a hidden
state and as i said you can also input x
all the time into your step function as
you see right here
but what you do is you unroll the
network for a number of steps
right independent of these output nodes
independent of this or if the halting
probability let's say we we unroll it
four four five steps right here
and at every point we get
a
output and a value y three y four this
is lambda 2 lambda 3 lambda 4. so at
training we simply unroll
until a a given step now there are some
technical
difficulties with doing with unrolling
for a finite amount of step like how do
you normalize the probability
distribution because essentially this
tree can go on until infinity
they find okay we we can simply
unroll until kind of the
rest probability the probability we
haven't used yet is is really small and
then just load that all into the last
step but these are technical uh
difficulties that you really only care
when you then go and implement
however so we unroll for a number of
steps and then um
our
we consider all the outputs at the same
time now this is one big difference i
believe to one of the previous networks
to this act so what act does it it
always unrolls and then the the output
of the network
so for ac the output of the network
would simply be a weighted output of the
lambda i y i okay
so the output of the network is always a
weighting between the different steps
okay and the network can decide okay how
do i want to weight the individual
outputs whereas here it's different here
the output is really either y1 or y2 or
y3 or y4 and
to in order to pack this into a single
loss function
um
what we can do sorry i should probably
leave this uh
in order to pack this into a single loss
function we simply take okay what's the
loss what would be the loss if we
answered y
one right
um what would be the loss and we weigh
that by the probability
and we say okay what would be the loss
of y2 we weigh it by the probability
that the network output right so now if
we and so on so plus
essentially we compute the expected uh
loss given the probabilities that the
network has output so now if we back
prop this
we back prop through these losses we
have of course two paths of back
dropping so we backdrop through the y's
which means um
let's at some so there's a loss right
and both these things
and these things go into the loss right
so the loss is
oh how bad is this
um times how probably it was and so on
so the back propagation path would
actually attack at two different paths
you can see so the back prop goes into y
because you want the network to compute
a
a better
output
but the proc propagation also goes into
the lambda because you want the network
to get better at uh estimating when its
output is good and when not this i see a
little bit as a tricky situation because
usually um
this this seems a little bit unstable
just from experience from other papers
and so on if you have a back prop
through two different things especially
that are appear to be multiplied
together and that you know the network
can now trade off one versus the other
which might you might think is desirable
right it can either choose to make its
output
better if it wants to keep the
probability high of outputting this
thing or it can just reduce the
probability that it's going to output
whatever it wants to output and
you know then it it doesn't have to
necessarily make the output itself
correct because the loss uh
the loss won't be as high for that
particular thing because the probability
of outputting it is low
the network essentially has a choice as
i said this might be desirable but
usually that's kind of unstable and um
i think this is just my personal opinion
i think a lot of
um why this might work might rest on
whether or not or
let's say the complexity itself
of assessing of making y better versus
adjusting these probabilities of course
yeah so
you see
if
the output y is very complex right then
um
this you know the same gradient signal
for that might mean much less than
simply reducing the probability okay
so if the output is very very complex
right not the problem but just the
output itself like how to arrive at an
output if the output is an entire pixel
map or something like this then and and
and that has dependencies and so on the
network might just choose to
always reduce the probability because
it's like well how am i gonna how am i
gonna make this better at all i don't
know i can just reduce the probability
i'm going to output this crap right
and it it will probably do this then for
every you know single step which you
know if a com if it's complex problem
makes sense but still
that's that would be a bit my my fear
here and
this is not really discussed in the
paper itself um
so i think the the fact that this works
might rely on sort of a balance of the
of the complexity or information content
that you get from the loss at the output
node versus the loss at the
probability node
so
okay enough about that so in yeah during
training you simply compute the expected
loss weighted by the probabilities and
then you can back prop through that and
i hope you can see the difference
between these two um one is a they both
seem to sum up somehow the outputs uh
weighted by these these factors however
one considers the actual output of the
network to be a weighted combination of
outputs of the individual steps where
the other one says no no the network
output is actually one of them we don't
know which one ergo for the loss we need
to compute the expectation of the loss
that seems to be a bit of a
let's just say uh yeah it seems to be a
more reasonable formulation though in
hindsight you can say many things um are
reasonable if they work better right
uh yeah so they discuss things like
maximum number of pondering steps and so
on again which i think is a um
technical detail and this is interesting
so there you have the training loss as
we just discussed now we've discussed
this part right here which they call the
reconstruction loss because you have
some kind of desired y and you have a y
that um comes from
this and i was a little bit wrong here
in my formulation of course the
expectation you don't have you don't
want to take the lambdas you actually
want to take the probabilities that each
thing happens which means that you you
need to compute this p number you know
going along this tree as we did
because the p is the actual probability
that you reach that node whereas the
lambda is only the conditional
probability that you reach a node given
you were at the previous node
so
yeah consider consider that if you if
you
are crazy enough to implement things
straight as i speak in the videos
lucid drains shout out um
the second part of the loss here and you
can see this is a hyper parameter so you
you're going to trade off two of two
losses right here because right now um
we saw okay you can either continue or
not continue and for the network you
know it might actually
be easier as i said if the loss of the
output comes reasonably complex right
here it might be easier to simply say
well in this case i'm just always going
to
reduce my probabilities
you might counteract this with having
this number of steps not like maximum
number of steps but essentially this
term here is what counteracts that
really there is a regularization term
on these probabilities as you can see
right here so we regularize with the kl
divergence which is sort of a distance
measure
don't tell this to a mathematician
it's a it's a a divergence it's a sort
of a distance measure
between the distribution that the
network outputs for the steps and this
thing right here which is a geometric
distribution
with this parameter and this parameter
lambda p is another hyperparameter so
what does that mean essentially
uh if you consider here the number of
steps that the network thinks right
think thinks for
what you regularize for this
distribution right here is a geometric
uh distribution
i'll go something like maybe you know
something like
this
so essentially a geometric distribution
is set it exactly computes this tree
that we computed right um so at each
step uh you can essentially stop
and the question is after you know this
distribution gives you
a indication
uh
after what's the probability that you
stop after one step two steps three
steps four steps considering the fact
that in order to stop after four steps
you already have to have made three
non-stopping steps except in the
geometric distribution the probability
of continuing is always the same whereas
in our network our network for each node
and the tree can output a different uh
probability otherwise you know there'd
be no point we can simply put in the
fixed distribution
now what that probability is of stopping
at each point that's exactly this lambda
p hyper parameter right here
so you
regularize for a kl
for this which means that you tell the
network look here is a
a reasonable
reasonable distribution of when you
should stop so you should stop
um
so it should be you know somewhat
probable that you stop after one step
and somewhat probable if you've already
done one step that you stop after two
steps and so on so you give it sort of a
default probability of stopping after
each step so if this is 0.1 for example
you tell the network essentially look at
any given step there is like a default
10 chance that you should stop i as a
designer of the algorithm think that's a
reasonable
uh prior to have now the network can
decide differently the network can
decide
no no no i actually want to stop way
earlier
right like like this
it puts much more
emphasis on the first steps which of
course in turn because you need to
normalize put less emphasis on the
latter steps
so the network can still decide to
violate this prior if the if effect may
reduce the loss for enough
so this is as i said a trade-off there
are two hyper parameters the geometric
distribution
shape and the amount that you regularize
by this kl divergence
and
yeah so
now we come into the experimental
results and these are pretty
pretty neat because
yeah they
i think these are
um straightforward experimental results
they're not super big large scale
results or anything like this but they
show that look on tasks where we sort of
know
that this dynamic computation has an
advantage uh our model will outperform
both previous attempts at dynamic
computation and especially networks that
have no
dynamic computation built in whatsoever
so this is the parity task which we're
going to look at as you can see here the
orange is this act which is the
previous work that they compare most
with that is most similar to them
you can see in terms of accuracy
pondernet
beats
this network by quite a bit also
appreciate the error bars in this one
they almost overlap but they don't so
you can say that you're definitely
better um
and
interestingly the number of compute
steps even though yeah the error bars
overlap as well here but pondernet
itself needs less compute steps which
might be you know i don't i don't know
why why exactly that happens but you can
speculate that it is because um
pondernet sort of fixes on a single like
it outputs a single answer whereas the
act it outputs this weighing of things
and therefore when it when it outputs
let's say the first step answer it
always needs to consider that this needs
to be compatible with potential future
steps so um
just formulating
just formulating how act outputs stuff
it seems like it becomes a lot less
dynamic because the output is always a
weighting of different outputs and
therefore the first steps they have to
they can't just output what they think
is the correct solution but they sort of
already have to incorporate the future
and estimate well if i'm going to
continue computing um then
you know there's going to be stuff added
to my output right here and they have to
take this into account so it can be
ironically less dynamic of a network and
that's why i think pondernet might need
less steps here i might be totally wrong
though
so this is the parity task and
specifically they train with
string lengths between you know
so this is a string length of one and
then string length of
we've before we had like eight right
something like this so they train up
from one until 49
lengths one until 49 and this is a
little bit important i think
because their training set contains all
of them which
you know
this is a little bit of an experimental
trick right
so in order for your network what you
wanted to learn is kind of the general
principle of parity independent of
string length so you construct the
training data set to be sort of a
distribution of lengths of string
um
rather than just strings of a of a fixed
length and then you assess their parity
so yeah that that's maybe a bit of a
lesson
uh for if you
do experiments construct your tasks
themselves already such that uh they
help find the correct solution right so
they train with strings of length one up
up until 49 right and then they try to
extrapolate which is this b right here
so this is extrapolation where then they
test so first here they test they train
on
small strings they test on small strings
here in b they train on the same small
strings up till length 49
but then as i understand it they give it
length 50 to what 99 or so uh in
or 96 it says it somewhere just longer
strings that it has been trained with
right and now that the setup is you know
clear it's clear why they did the
different length strings in the training
set and not just fixed length strings
because
uh there's a reasonable chance the
network does not learn to extrapolate
just from one
particular or two particular lengths of
string
nevertheless
they test
how does the network extrapolate to
longer strings and you can see right
here that act
even though it also has been trained on
the dynamic length uh strings
it is that's 50 right that's pure chance
so
it's a parity task right it's the output
is either
odd or even
so act
um just gets a pure random chance as a
result whereas the pondernet as you can
see has like an accuracy of 0.9 which i
guess is pretty good
especially on strings that are so long
you've never seen them
so
what can we read from this i'm not
exactly sure there's always the
possibility that you know they've just
trained a ct wrong or something like
this but it's also it's also reasonable
to say that just how the previous models
were constructed
either they didn't learn the concept or
their their output is just weird in the
way ict is
or
since acts bias gradients estimates and
pondernet doesn't
yada yada we don't know what we do know
is that in their experiments
this pondernet was actually able to
solve the extrapolation task right here
the interesting thing is
that if you look at the number of
compute steps done
you can see that pondernet in
contrast to what it was trained with
during inference
sorry that's an alarm
in
in contrast to what it was trained with
during inference during inference it has
like
two point between two point five and
three steps let's say three steps
computes for about three steps uh during
inference time that's what it decides on
for the smaller strings yet the same
model right train on the same strings
this is the same model during inference
time on the longer strings
all of a sudden
it raises its compute to five steps
right whereas act okay act doesn't work
in the in this one it it just decides to
stick around uh two or three steps as it
does in training right so
the authors sort of
claim that this is good evidence that
pondernet learns uh
to solve the actual task right here and
as the task gets more complex pondernet
needs more steps to think about the task
and this might be exactly you know what
we saw that you have some sort of a
string of zeros and ones
and you learn during training you learn
a how to take one of these maybe in
multiple steps and get an output but now
you also you have a longer string right
well so now what you can do is you can
also learn an output for this one and
now you have two outputs right and now
you can learn a series of steps uh to
transform the two outputs here
into a single output and that might just
need
one or two more computation steps which
is exactly what we see right here
happening
so it's a good it's a good indication
that something like this is happening i
would be wondering pondering one might
say haha
if
you know how this actually happens like
like what do the individual computation
steps represent is it in fact a
for example in this parity task is the
network going about this task in a
hierarchical fashion
you know like like i've shown here is it
something different is it going about it
in sort of a purely recurrent fashion
where even though we as i understand it
we input the entire string at the
beginning uh does it only look at the
string position by position or you know
how does this work
how does the scaling behave in general
if you know they only show
small strings large strings but how does
it behave in general as you go up
uh the length and so on it would be
really interesting to introspect this
model a little bit more than simply
showing
kind of um
you know end results here of the
individual tasks
okay what they also find is that the
hyper parameter how you regularize the
shape we've seen this up here
how you regularize this shape um
is you know that is a hyperparameter but
it doesn't seem to be terribly important
again they compare to act which has
another hyperparameter that does the
similar thing that regularizes the shape
of the
um
of the desired
halting distribution which they call tau
now tau doesn't mean a particular thing
in
so they say it does not have any
straightforward interpretation though i
guess the
authors of act might disagree um but as
you can see
here so if i draw the the means there is
a region where
the tau per where
a selection of tau performs high though
you have to say see that is all around
sort of the same value of like five e
minus four or something like this and
then for the other values that you might
set it for it simply doesn't work at all
so you the authors claim you have to hit
this tau uh pretty correctly in order to
even get the network to do anything
whereas they claim in pondernet this
variable right here
first of all it's between zero and one
and not just an arbitrary value right
because it's a probability um
and they claim that you know it kind of
works for
for most things except
this one right here where essentially
you bias the network to just output
everything after one step so the trick
is for the geometric distribution you
have to take the inverse so 1 over this
lambda p and that will give you the
expected number of steps that the
network would compute according to this
prior so when you put in 0.9
that would essentially be a single step
that you ask the network to do but for
all the other things well you you judge
for yourself uh whether
whether this here
is really
good but what you can say is that look
it goes from zero to one so you have a
clear range and for most of that range
the the thing seems to work okay-ish
and
what they highlight is even down here so
even if they do this even if they set
lambda p to 1 or sorry
2.1 which would essentially bias the
network towards 10 steps
so that the prior is please do 10 steps
of computation
in this parity task as i understand it
um even for that point one you can see
the network it doesn't do ten steps it
actually uh also goes towards three four
or five steps most of the time so the
network
learns to be somewhat robust to this
prior distribution i mean i guess that's
also a function largely of the uh hyper
parameter here where you trade it off we
don't know the effect of that just from
the paper
but even you know even if they set that
to really low it's
it it
of course then the network is kind of
robust to the choice of the lambda p yet
it's still good news because that means
it would mean you wouldn't have to
regularize the the model
super heavily in order to get it to work
okay they go into two other tasks right
here again these aren't tasks that you
might necessarily know they are tasks
where this type of computation shines uh
particularly and yeah as i said i see
the paper more as sort of an interesting
and interesting task an interesting
niche task subtask you might say of of
connecting deep learning and classic
algorithms there are a number of things
that i think you can do right here to
extend this
so it's completely thinkable that
you know the loss might be a bit
different that you don't ask the network
to output the direct answer at each
point but you know you might
you might want to attach memories and so
on at at these output nodes um
you might want it want them to output
intermediate results or something like
this
another thing you could do is you could
work with sort of adversarial
losses instead of
of um you know kind of reconstruction
losses or whatnot so you could you could
have some sort of a
gan going on inside of this um in order
to decide on the on the stopping
probability uh there's lots of stuff um
one can fiddle around with this uh type
of of network
um you can even think of of crazier
architectures i don't know hop field
like uh structures where you decide you
know how far you iterate
because
you don't you may not always want to
trade until fixed points
i don't know i'm just i'm just talking
crap right now
okay uh
one last shout out to the broader impact
statement of this paper what a beautiful
beautiful piece of um
of writing so essentially they say well
um
this enables neurals neural networks to
adapt their computational complexity to
the tasks they are trying to solve
you know neural networks are good but
currently they require much time
expensive hardware
they often fail pondernet expands the
capabilities they say look it you know
it can do this it can do that
makes it particularly well suited for
platforms with limited resources such as
mobile phones which
is a good thing right
it can also generalize better
uh that means it's better for real world
problems
and they say we encourage other
researchers to pursue the questions we
have considered on this work we believe
that biasing neural network
architectures to behave more like
algorithms and less like flat mappings
will help developing deep learning
methods to their full potential
and that is indeed the broader impact of
this work like that is
that's the impact it had on me and
that's the impact that it it should have
um
yeah i'm not like
at today's conferences that most might
be kicked out because of course it
doesn't say technology good technology
bad technology bias
but you know
respect for that and that was it for me
let me know what you think and bye bye